bonsoir mesdames et messieurs la
première chose sur laquelle les
candidats se sont prononcés c'est le
prix de l'immobilier totalement chez
astor
l'éloge d'un prix modique beaucoup de
monde car nous faisons si on veut avoir
une incidence sur les prix au niveau de
l'habitation pour l'accès à la propriété
et tout ce qui est abordable on a besoin
de doper l'offre quand on regarde les
villes comme toronto ou vancouver qui
ont perdu la bataille c'est parce qu'il
n'y avait pas de réglementation ils ont
laissé le marché
ils l'ont laissé faire ça pas fonctionné
denis coderre abrogerait le règlement
qui impose aux promoteurs des quotas de
logements sociaux et abordables
denis coderre veut mettre les choses au
clair il ya aucun anti vélo ici moi
aussi j'en fais du vélo forme et elle
est anti voiture faut arrêter ne pas
travailler dans un contexte de
cohabitation
une occasion pour valérie plantes de
vanter son réseau express vélo sur un
axe majeur du centre-ville je pense que
le rêve saint denis en est le meilleur
exemple ça avait été refait à
l'identique
on a décidé un staline esclaves un
million de passages qui a été célébrée
dimanche et 30 nouveaux commerces qui se
sont installés sur saint denis
un thème cher à denis coderre plus
particulièrement la sécurité sur le
terrain les gens par les gens ont besoin
d'outils les gens besoin d'avoir plus de
policiers sur le terrain dire qu'elle
avait des dangereuses venant de la
bouche du candidat à la mairie trop que
ces mets de côté tout le travail de
celles et ceux qui assurent notre
protection questions simples liés à
l'environnement sur la golf d'anjou est
ce qu'on protège où on développe un pro
tech débat on développe mais on peut pas
faire du développement économique au
détriment du développement vers
le développement primes et soldes d'été
voici ce qu'il a dit à la question sur
son style de leadership faut faire une
distinction détermination et arrogance
aux deux quant à l'idée de rester dans
l'opposition en cas de défaite c'est oui
pour valérie plante un plan b et qu'elle
ne souhaite pas pensé denis coderre ici
mathieu prost radio canada montréal